en este ejercicio nos piden que
encontremos el mínimo común múltiplo que
ahora vamos a llamar mcm para que sea
más fácil de referirnos a él y nos piden
encontrar el mcm de estos dos polinomios
trecet a kubica menos 6 z cuadrada menos
9 z y el otro polinomio es 7 z a la
cuarta más 21 z cúbica más 14 z cuadrada
verdad entonces el primero pensemos si
nos preguntaran por ejemplo cuál es el
mínimo común múltiplo de dos números
verdad de una forma de de pensarlo por
ejemplo por ejemplo nos fijamos en sus
múltiplos digamos de 4 y 6 pensemos en
los múltiplos de 4 y 6 muy bien entonces
si pensamos en los múltiplos por ejemplo
de 4 tendríamos a 8 a 12
a 16 y así podríamos seguir nos verdad
si pensamos en los múltiplos de 6
tendríamos 12 18 24 y podríamos también
seguirnos hacia adelante verdad entonces
en realidad estos dos números 4 y 6
pueden tener varios múltiplos en común
verdad pero lo que nos piden es
encontrar el más chico de ellos entonces
por ejemplo aquí podemos ver que 12 es
un múltiplo en común de 4 y 6 y es el
más chico de todos los múltiplos con
digamos que coincide en verdad esto el
12 es un múltiplo común de 4 y 6 y
además es el más chico verdad y otra
forma de pensarlo es tratando de
descomponer en factores primos a 4 y 6
por ejemplo a 4 lo podemos escribir como
2 x 2 verdad y 6 a 6 lo podemos escribir
como 2 x 3
entonces el mínimo común múltiplo
como un múltiplo de 4 y 6 debe tener
todos los factores de 4 y 6 y tratar de
que no tengan más de eso es verdad
entonces por ejemplo para qué bueno es
este mínimo común múltiplo debe tener
estos dos factores 2 verdad debe tener
estos dos factores 2 y también debe
tener el factor 2 y el factor 3 para que
para que sea un múltiplo de 6 verdad
pero aquí ya tenemos un factor 2
entonces lo único que faltaría es poner
un factor 3 entonces aquí tenemos estos
dos factores 2 que corresponden a 4 y
también tenemos 2 y 3 que corresponden a
6 entonces este esta multiplicación
sería 2 por 2 son 4 por 3 son 12 muy
bien entonces esta es otra forma de
encontrar el mínimo común múltiplo de
dos números verdad lo importante es que
debe tener todos los factores de ambos
números y no más verdad debe tener el
mínimo número de factores posibles pero
que complete en todos los factores de
estos
no menos entonces cuando cuando pensamos
digamos esta idea para polinomios
esencialmente es lo mismo pero
necesitamos ver quiénes son los factores
de los polinomios verdad así que el
mínimo común múltiplo de dos polinomios
debe contener a todos los factores de
ambos y no más de lo necesario verdad
entonces en realidad digamos un múltiplo
de ambos polinomios se podría encontrar
simplemente multiplicando lo es pero
queremos el mínimo común múltiplo así
que primero vamos a tratar de factorizar
estos polinomios muy bien entonces
empecemos factor izando esta expresión
de aquí 3 zeta cúbica menos 6 se está
cuadrada menos 9 zeta y podríamos ver
por ejemplo que este polinomio tiene un
factor 3 c está verdad es divisible
entre 3 todos estos i salut tienen un
factor 7 entonces podemos factorizar 3
zeta y ahora 3 zeta por zeta cuadrada
nos da 3 z kubica
menos 3 por 2 nos dará 6 y z por z nos
da z cuadrada y finalmente 3 z por menos
3 nos da menos 9 z verdad entonces ahora
podríamos tratar de pensar en factorizar
este polinomio de grado 2 verdad
entonces una forma de pensar esto es
buscar dos números que multiplicados me
den menos 3 pero que sumados nos den
menos 2 verdad entonces por ejemplo
funcionaría menos 3 y más 1 verdad
entonces aquí vamos a poner 3 z que
multiplica a z más 1 por zeta menos 3
verdad menos tres más uno son menos dos
y menos tres por uno es menos tres
entonces aquí ya tenemos la
factorización de esta expresión ahora
vamos con el segundo polinomio
sería 7z a la cuarta más 21 zeta cúbica
más 14z cuadrada muy bien podríamos ver
aquí que podríamos factorizar por
ejemplo 7 se está cuadrada 7 se está
cuadrada verdad todos estos números son
divisibles entre 7 y todos tienen al
menos una seta cuadrada verdad ahora
bien esto a quien tendría que
multiplicar bueno 777 se está cuadrada x
se está cuadrada nos da 7 z a la cuarta
más 7 se está cuadrada por 3 z verdad
nos da 21 set a kubica + 2 verdad aquí 2
por 77 cuadrada nos da 14 c está
cuadrada muy bien y otra vez tratamos de
factorizar esta expresión de aquí verdad
sería dos números que multiplicados me
den 2 y suma 2 3
eso es 2 y 1 verdad entonces 7 se está
cuadrada que multiplica
uno por z
2 esta es una factorización para esta
expresión verdad entonces ya factor
izamos estos dos polinomios de la misma
forma que factor izamos a los a los
números de acá verdad entonces ahora
tenemos que tomar los factores
necesarios para construir un múltiplo en
común verdad entonces por ejemplo
empecemos de este lado
tomemos 3 zeta por zeta más uno por zeta
menos 3 verdad de hecho de hecho voy a
hacer un poquito más claro esto voy a
ponerlo así voy a poner 3 x se está muy
bien para que se vea que tenemos todos
estos factores muy bien ahora
necesitamos un factor 7 verdad y ese no
lo encontramos en estos que ya hemos
elegido entonces vamos a tener que
agregar un factor 7 necesitamos se está
cuadrada que lo podemos ver como zeta
por zeta y aquí ya tenemos una zeta
entonces podríamos agregar otras z aquí
digamos o bien simplemente decir
que estas dos zetas se vuelven z
cuadrada verdad y finalmente agregamos
un zeta más uno pero ese ya está aquí
este factor se está más o no ya lo
teníamos y sólo nos faltaba agregar z
más 2 muy bien entonces digamos poniendo
ya esto en limpio con un color más
neutro tendríamos 7 por 3 que son 21 se
está cuadrada por zeta más 1 por zeta
menos 3 por zeta más 2 y aquí ya tenemos
nuestro mínimo común múltiplo para estos
dos polinomios y de verdad me gustaría
que notarás que estamos haciendo
exactamente lo mismo que cuando
hablábamos de números verdad en realidad
estábamos descomponiendo en factores por
ejemplo para los números descomponemos
en factores primos y vemos que el mínimo
común múltiplo debe contener a todos los
factores de ambos pero no más de ello
verdad por ejemplo por aquí podríamos
multiplicar por
aquí podríamos multiplicar por 100
verdad pero eso ya no sería el mismo ya
no sería el mínimo común múltiplo verdad
lo mismo acá podríamos multiplicar por
100 y tener 1200 pero este ya no sería
el mínimo común múltiplo de estos dos
números así que en realidad esto no es
el mínimo común múltiplo pero esto sí
que es el mínimo común múltiplo de estos
dos polinomios